You may remember Who Framed Roger Rabbit as
a beloved animated film from your childhood,
but if you watch it as an adult, you might
be shocked at its explicit content.
"So I took a couple'a dirty pictures, so kill
me."
"I already got a stiff on my hands, thank
you."
From the movie's colorful language to its
varied pop culture references, to the bodacious
Jessica Rabbit, here are some fascinating
things about Who Framed Roger Rabbit you only
notice as an adult.
Pervy Herman
As kids we may have known something wasn't
right about a cartoon baby smoking a giant
cigar, but the sexual predilections of Baby
Herman may have gone over our innocent little
heads.
"My problem is I got a 50-year-old's lust
and a three-year-old's dinky."
Baby Herman might look sweet, but that's just
a part he plays in the movies; Herman is a
total perv.
When we first meet him, he takes a peek up
a crew member's skirt, and when Herman goes
to see Eddie, Herman slaps his lady friend
on the butt.
Not exactly the kind of things you'd want
kids to emulate.
Pattycake
When Eddie captures Jessica Rabbit and Marvin
Acme playing "pattycake" in her dressing room,
he thinks he's struck gold to convince Roger
that his wife is cheating on him.
"Pattycake, pattycake, pattycake!"
Later, the pictures show that Jessica and
Marvin really were playing pattycake, but
judging by Roger's reaction, they may as well
have been playing bury the carrot instead.
Whether or not pattycake is the toon equivalent
of sex, if you were under the age of 12 when
you saw this movie, hopefully the entire bit
would've been lost on you.
Bad rabbit
As Jessica Rabbit says,
"I'm not bad, I'm just drawn that way."
And in one case, that's definitely true.
On the original Laserdisc version, when Jessica
and Eddie are in a high speed chase and thrown
from the taxi, there's a moment where her
dress reveals a little more than you'd expect
in a kids' movie.
But of course, nothing about Jessica Rabbit
is exactly "family friendly."
"Nice booby trap."
Alcoholic Eddie
Eddie Valiant spends much of the movie in
Dolores' bar, and when he's not there, he's
back in his office, drowning his sorrows.
Eddie's brother, who was also his partner,
was killed by a toon, and it's obvious that
Eddie is self-medicating his pain with the
help of booze.
Watching the movie as an adult, it's obvious
that Eddie is a full-blown alcoholic.
But the movie at least tries to warn its younger
audience members about the dangers of alcohol.
When Roger is given a drink after discovering
Jessica's infidelity, the results are pretty
messy.
Probate problems
In the scene where Eddie's trying to get his
handcuffs off, Eddie suggests that Dolores
go downtown to check the probate on Acme's
will, a word Roger clearly misinterprets.
"My Uncle Thumper had a problem with his probate
and he had to take big pills and drink lots
of water!"
Chances are you had no idea what a prostate
was when you were a kid.
Apparently neither does Roger.
Inhuman Doom
The infamous shoe-melting scene in Who Framed
Roger Rabbit is one of the most traumatic
cinematic moments of our childhood.
Thanks to Christopher Lloyd's terrifying performance,
Judge Doom goes down in the history books
as one of the scariest movie villains ever.
It's hard to spot through his glasses—and
he has some animated help at the end of the
movie—but hardcore fans of the film may
have noticed that Lloyd does something inhuman
in every scene he appears in: he never blinks.
Terrifying.
Invisible Harvey
When Judge Doom storms the bar looking for
Roger, one of the patrons seems like he's
about to give up Roger's hiding spot.
And then he does this:
"Say hello, Harvey."
It's a pretty random joke… unless you get
the reference.
The man at the bar was referring to Harvey,
a 1950 comedy about an invisible rabbit starring
Jimmy Stewart.
And it just so happens that the main character
is an alcoholic like Eddie who spends most
of his time in a bar.
Singing Sword
Looking for a weapon in the final showdown
with Judge Doom, Eddie grabs a prop out of
a box in the warehouse: the singing sword.
"Oh, I know it's strictly taboooo!"
Older viewers probably recognized the sword
as none other than Frank Sinatra.
But that's not the only pop culture reference
packed into this short bit at the end of the
film.
Eddie's last name, Valiant, is a reference
to the Prince Valiant comic strip of the late
1930s and 40s—in it, Prince Valiant's weapon
of choice is… you guessed it, a singing
sword.
Hand-drawn racism
Who Framed Roger Rabbit is packed with adult
themes, one of the biggest of which is its
depiction of racism in Hollywood.
Cartoons are definitely being treated as second-class
citizens, especially under the reign of Judge
Doom, who is overtly racist against animated
figures.
In the movie, the toons work as performers
and waiters at the club where Jessica sings,
but the only patrons are humans.
In the end, Roger Rabbit's achievements in
animation are only bolstered by this extended
metaphor on racism and segregation.
It's fascinating to re-watch the movie as
an adult while keeping this metaphor in mind.
"The best part is, they work for peanuts."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!